je reçois maintenant jean louis aubert
jean louis aubert messieurs et voilà
jean louis aubert noël mamère et je vais
tessier voilà alors jean louis aubert
pas inutile de le présenter pour moi
d'arriver après j'arrive et le coeur
léger jamais pour faire voilà et non pas
du tout et donc je trouve maintenant on
sait rien n'est comme avant
ouais jean louis aubert fondateur et
songwriter du plus grand groupe français
de rock n roll téléphone et puis après
le split une carrière solo plus ou moins
solo avec certains autres membres du
groupe
musique mais ça l'est
jean
ja
il
là
ses parents
je marchais le fait sur une étrange it
et je crois que j'ai rêvé
m
non
moi
et
j'aime quand
j'aimais
à
et voilà jean louis aubert
oui mais bon sang comme on vient de le
voir
les mélodies sont bonnes patricia la
voyante c'est plutôt lui la bombe
humaine après new york avec toi et après
je rêvais d'un autre monde
et oui je rêvais d'un autre monde
aujourd'hui jean louis aubert sort un
nouvel album qui s'appelle comme un
accord serait comment on fait jean louis
c'est la tradition dans cette émission
attention on joue devant notre
étant déçus même un président de la
république le fait vous l'avez fait d'y
donner voilà est le premier single donc
s'appelle alter ego dont beaucoup à
radio en ce moment
voilà tu es un ego jean louis aubert
nouvel album nouveau single vous avez
fait un concert le 22 octobre à l'elysée
montmartre un duo avec axel bauer vous
allez jouer un autre monde et est un des
grands succès d'axel bauer s'appelle
éteint la lumière et axel bauer il était
au concert des who
en 69 au théâtre des champs-elysées
étaient tous et voulzy tous les gens qui
étaient à ce concert sont devenus des
amis
ouais ben est plein on fait de la
musique ob c'est vrai ça a tout
déclenché moi c'est à cause de ce
concert que que j'ai décroché la guitare
de repas par jour
alors jean louis aubert c'était en 1955
à nantua dans l'ain et votre père était
sous préfet mai mais à un sous préfet
aux champs caval'art effet folle ou pas
tellement de pouvoir ils croyaient pas à
son business
non non il m'a bien montrer l'envers du
décor et il se méfiait des politiques
mais vous avez passé cinq ans en
captivité et que ça l'avait un peu guéri
peut-être des idéologies ils me disent
mais cet appareil
sage il ya un nouveau jour ce soir pour
dire mais il m'a toujours dit ce en
captivité que j'étais le plus libre
parce que chacun prenait sa place pour
aider les autres
naturellement ceux qui savaient trafic
et boîtes de conserve pour faire des
réchauds et ça et lui c'est là qu'il a
fait de la musique et comme il
connaissait beaucoup de deux poèmes par
coeur il récitait sa ses copains il
s'occuper un peu de leur leur esprit
alors effectivement il dessine et y
jouer de la guitare il accrocher la
guitare dans votre chambre
est ce que c'est un signe à votre avis
je sais pas en tout cas jamais sage qui
vous passent et je pense mais surtout je
sais que quand j'ai décroché à guiza la
première fois que j'ai fait des
premières notes il a fait d'autres cieux
que quand j'avais des bonnes notes à
l'école louis lumière de jean louis
aubert a été en fait un artiste refoulé
et qui était passionné de grecs
d'étymologie et qu'ils faisaient l'amour
des mots sur mon père ce n'est pas à
l'école
voilà donc fils de sous préfet vous
déménagez beaucouzé de nantua à senlis
une enfance plutôt plutôt dorée des
grandes maisons des chauffeurs des des
bonnes des jardins des bonne bonne bonne
bonne
bah non c'est sympa de s'appeler
mignonne elle va montrer son cul voilà
il en avait aussi accroché dans sa
chambre alors une enfance assez
classique finalement vous étiez vous
étiez scouts on forme que enfin voilà on
imagine mal un patent dans une enfance
assez osée que vos deux soeurs et en
fait vous ne réaliserez que bien plus
tard à quel point vous aviez souffert la
maison pente de vos parents ça sera dur
et comment non non c'est à dire quand on
est arrivé à paris on s'y retrouver dans
un appartement à ces petits d'une
coexistence et là j'ai découvert un peu
la vie avec mes parents et mes parents
ils ont aussi découvert la vie avec
honda en promiscuité et là il ya 68
alors en 68 vous avait 13 ans et là
c'est la révolte qui commence c'est à
dire voilà le rockeur nez de gaulle qui
symbolise l'autorité parentale vassy et
bien alors là vous commencez à discuter
avec les trotskistes avec les maoïstes
et anarchie et tout ça les
situationnistes et tout ça vous oblige à
lire mars bakounine pour voir des
arguments pour voir discuter
ouais enfin moi je survolais alors c'est
à la fois l'époque vous achetez votre
premier disque des beatles et la fois
l'époque où vos parents vous emmène de
force au défi les gaullistes des champs
elysées le 30 juin 68 et ça aussi ça
vous a guéri de la politique ce défilé
obligatoire vous êtes plus jamais voter
après non non ce qui m'a d'abord je suis
pas si je suis guéri de la politique je
m'intéresse au monde mais aussi le c'est
mon père quand j'étais petit disait
quand il parlait des députés en
particulier ils ont ils trouvé sa fin
mais ça magouille est beaucoup à cette
époque-là leur maintenance ont tous
clean et donc pas vous croyez pas trop à
la politique vous dites je n'oublie pas
que hitler a été élu au suffrage
universel c'est la pure vérité et vous
dites si le front national passé grâce à
des élections démocratiques
je n'accepterai pas les résultats je ne
suis pas démocrate à ce point c'est à
dire qu'effectivement vous avez une
méfiance de la politique je trouve que
quand on
je devrais peut-être pas dire ça ça
m'est arrivé de voter là j'ai essayé
pour voir c'était bizarre
normalement quand on vote on est censé
accepter le résultat des urnes way et
c'est ça peut être embêtant
enfin c'est un peu du sort c'est comme
ça c'est quand il me semble qu entendez
des chansons ou envie d'en parler ici on
peut voter aussi fine soit parce que
c'est un peu on peut dire des choses ni
noire ni blanche large mais si un
président de république d'extrême droite
était élu au suffrage universel vous ne
reconnaîtrez pas le verdict des urnes à
nant et vous noël moi je me dirais que
c'est les français ont mérité ce qu'ils
auront été mais je sur est un peu comme
jean louis oui je le serai plutôt prêts
à prendre le maquis qu'autre chose que
je me battrai massinon et le gène
accepterait pourra effectivement que un
pays se livrent aux mains d'un facho
c'est ce que vient de faire l'italie et
réduire jusqu au 10 1
ces pays et l'italie philippe oui moi
moi moi c'est pareil c'est pareil je
suis pas j'ai jamais bien compris ni
admis la phrase de voltaire qui dirait
ici je suis pas d'accord avec vous vos
idées je mourrai pour que vous puissiez
les exprimer
non c'est plutôt du côté de saint-just
peuvent liberté pour les ennemis de la
liberté
par exemple j'aurais bien aimé avant une
situation aussi une citation ne voulait
pas
c'est vrai qu'on attendait le témoignage
de latifa on se dit qu'il ya pas de
liberté pour les ennemis des libertés
c'est à peu près ce qu'on peut en
déduire oui alors en 69 vous avez 14 ans
et là effectivement oui les ou sur scène
donc là théâtre des champs-élysées grand
moment et après le concert vous prenez
la guitare theetge plus jamais lâcher
quoi ça a été pour vous là le chemin de
damas quoi ouais ouais c'était moi
c'était très important surtout que en
allant à ce concert il y avait une pièce
d'art à bâle où les filles vous avez les
seins nus sur la photo donc avec mon
copain on avait 14 ans on y est allé et
et on a été reçus par des gens très
cultivés qui était très content de voir
des mots rentrer mon a pas dit que c'est
pour les saints et il ya eu un vent de
liberté un peu culturel caracas ou fait
sur nous ça pue ce concert des cultures
est le premier groupe à 15 ans le
premier groupe savait le masturbation
pour le savoir tout est lié avec le vif
du jury et le livre de l'hydra syrien et
puis antoine de caunes and de koné abbas
qu'il vient principalement s'il ya une
belle batterie 1 après vous avez au
lycée pasteur à neuilly vous avez jugnot
comme pion est sévère à white et paris
c'est pas rigolo
il y avait tous les l'équipe du splendid
donc c'est assez marrant guatelli permis
avait il été pion il aimait ça confié
aurait dû bac vous savez c'est pas
scolarité pas terrible et deux moyennes
vous êtes viré de pasteur vous retrouver
un sourire carnot et à carnot vous
rencontrer louis bertignac donc voilà
les choses commençaient à un petit peu
s'établir là on commence à voir un peu
là la génèse de la faire ensuite je les
la fac de vincennes c'était énorme la
fac de vincennes
c'était tout sauf une fac quoi c'est
vrai moi j'ai passé un président c'était
bon alors vous faites de la musicologie
si vous avez peur du tout là si je
continue je vais finir prof de musique
c'est ça mais c'était très très
instructif parce que j'ai vu plein de
choses que je voulais pas faire
j'ai vu ce que je voulais pas faire
c'est d'essayer d'apprendre sur le tas
ouais on me dit de donc voyage aux usa
ce moment-là voyage initiatique aux usa
qui vous a quelque part guéri de
l'american dream alors que vous faites à
la fois la manche bon jouer comme ça
pour les usa c'est l'atlantique
c'était à voir l'angleterre et est à la
fois voyez un concert de jefferson
airplane donc tout ça vous remplit les
amants de bonheur il malgré tout vous
revenez un peu gris du rêve américain
savait pour pourquoi vous il ya eu
plusieurs bascule
mais à ce concert de jefferson starship
à l'époque with le guitariste avait des
cheveux des baskets en drapeau américain
et samaa il sert et c'est ce type et non
retour vont rencontrer richard kolinka
donc et vous former ses molina
évidemment à cause de la chanson des
beatles and the walrus où il ya ces
molina pile car jacking forme des dogues
ice et vous faites des boomers lui en
smoking se faisait qu'on fait des
rallyes dans le 16e et oblige nous
habiller en smoking non à billes être
plus on est habillé zazou et puissance
est rentré dans les rallyes du cese
habillé sans ce matin j'ai vu des trucs
très très décadent en avant du 16e trou
fait une retraite dans une grotte à
ibiza oui on va tous fait un
rassurez-vous vous mangez du lait et du
miel uniquement du lait et du miel
non mais on continue à faire la manche
pour susi et en dirait libye saavedra
c'était chansons de blau pedra et là
vous composer mais trop c'est trop
et après tout s'organise on a écouté ce
que ça a donné